hi there guys I'm new seat here with
another GameSpot news update for you
square enix have revealed some pretty
impressive looking sales figures for
their turn-based JRPG bravely default
the 3ds only title has topped 400,000
units in japan and 600,000 everywhere
else in the world but sakura japanese
website dengeki online using my
incredible math skills i reckon that's
over 1 million units sold is has
confirmed by the game's official Twitter
account that is indeed over 1 million
units sold it's a great day for Square
Enix and math geeks are like originally
envisioned to be a Final Fantasy title
bravely default and strong response from
both critics and fans you felt it return
to the core of final fantasy that have
been lost in the series most recent
entries let's all just take a moment to
remember lightning returns bravely
default with developed by Square Enix
but ended up being published outside of
Japan by Nintendo who announced earlier
this year that didn't sold over 200,000
copies in three weeks following its
north american release date back in
February so pretty smart move so what a
square enix learned from the game
success well according to president
Yosuke Matsuda is that they need to
focus more on what their core fans want
for the new games will be developing
from this point on and while this may
sound a bit extreme we've been talking
about making them as heavy JRPGs which
hopefully we'll see more of in bravely
default already announced sequel bravely
second are you happy to c square return
to their core JRPG roots he was confused
as I am by the name bravely second let
us know in the comments for the latest
gaming queries stay tuned here to
gamespot